Nintendo is likely the most classic and
well-known game company in the entire
world they've made nostalgic fun games
that have captivated hundreds of
millions of people across multiple
Generations I mean the switch alone has
sold well over a 100 million units and
they've even had a movie come out about
one of their biggest IPS Mario but
behind all these layers the sad reality
is that Nintendo has actually been
undergoing a massive recession now it's
not like they about to go bankrupt or
something but they have been losing
ground for over 15 years now way back in
2009 for example Nintendo was pulling in
over $17 billion in Revenue over the
next decade this would dropped nearly
80% all the way down to $3.6 billion
since then they have been staging a
pretty strong recovery with the switch
and their mobile games but even with
that Nintendo has only been able to
recover to a little over $10 billion in
revenue and that's not even accounting
for inflation if we throw inflation into
the mix we'll see that Nintendo is only
pulling in about half of what they were
back in 2009 and that's just the revenue
side of things if we look at the stock
side of things we'll see that Nintendo
is struggling to surpass their 2007 high
and again that's not even accounting for
inflation and what's worse is that to
make the switch work Nintendo had to
basically cannibalize their entire
business and bet it all on the switch so
now they're less Diversified and more
volatile than ever and this becomes
especially dangerous given that we're
approaching the end of the switch's life
cycle with it already being out for
nearly 7 years now given that the switch
is still selling quite well it seems
that Nintendo is willing to keep it
around for an extra year or two but
sooner or later Nintendo will have to
release a new console which as we've
seen in the past is often hit or miss so
join me as as we take a closer look at
what happened to Nintendo and their
struggle to recapture their former
glory taking a look back we can't talk
about the Legacy and success of Nintendo
without mentioning the NES and SNES
compared to Modern console sales these
systems didn't actually sell all that
well coming in at 61 million units and
41 million units respectively but their
impact on the gaming industry was much
larger than just these numbers these
consoles are what really put Nintendo on
the global map introducing franchises
like Mario and Zelda to the entire world
Nintendo had a much different approach
back then as well it was all about
pushing the boundaries in terms of power
performance and Innovation the Nintendo
64 for example basically redefined the
entire gaming industry with its
revolutionary experimentation with with
3D Graphics fun fact Nintendo was even
experimenting with VR way back in 1995
with the launch of the Nintendo Virtual
Boy and all of that was just on the
console side of Nintendo Nintendo was
also making substantial progress on the
handheld side of things with the Game
Boy and later the DS but moving into the
2000s Nintendo would flip all of this on
its head instead of continuing to push
the boundaries with the performance and
the graphics Nintendo would decide to
experiment with with their first gimmick
motion controls it turns out that motion
controls are actually an extremely
heated topic and much of the core Gaming
Community hates them with a passion and
when you hear them out it's not
surprising why for starters motion
controls are inherently less reliable
than buttons and this makes a big
difference when it comes to more intense
games and second of all people play
video games to relax and chill out not
stand up and move all over the place but
while the Wii and its motion controls
didn't appeal to the hardcore Gamers you
know who it did appeal to basically
everyone else and I don't mean that in a
metaphorical sense the Wii is probably
the only console in history that
grandparents bought not as a Christmas
present but as a console for themselves
the idea was that games like we fit and
Dance Dance Revolution were a fun way to
stay fit and active for any age group
and as for younger kids well being able
to swing a Wii remote as a golf club or
a baseball bat or a tennis bracket was a
lot cooler than just pressing buttons
and all of this led to the Wii becoming
Nintendo's best-selling Home console of
all time selling just over 100 million
units motion controls weren't the only
gimmick that Nintendo was experimenting
with though after producing single
screen handheld devices for over a
decade for whatever reason Nintendo
would decide to make the DS a dual
screen system this functionality was
basically never useful in any game but
that didn't really matter because it
gave the DS a cool factor that helped it
become the most successful handheld of
all time selling over 150 million units
this concurrent explosion of the Wii and
DS made the late 2000s a magical time
period for Nintendo but it also led to a
rather faulty line of reasoning the idea
that Nintendo needed some sort of
gimmick to maximize sales and to reach
as many people as possible the reality
was that this was never what made
Nintendo successful in the first place
but none Ness Nintendo would end up
doubling down on gimmicks and they would
find out the hard way that this wouldn't
always end
well Nintendo's next big gimmick was of
course 3D with the 3DS around the time
that the 3DS launched 3D TVs were
gaining a bunch of steam due to Avatar
Avatar had shown that 3D could be done
in a tasteful cinematic way that that
enhance the user experience and given
that Avatar would go on to be the
biggest box office hit of all time it's
no wonder why TV makers and eventually
Nintendo also wanted a piece of the pie
but as you would guess their
implementation of 3D was nothing like
Avatar's implementation Nintendo's
implementation of 3D wasn't an artistic
Choice it was an eye-catching feature to
sell consoles which it did somewhat do
the 3DS only sold about half as well as
the DS but that still added up to a
solid 75 million units the same however
could not be said about the Wii U the
Wii U's gimmick was that you could play
console games on a handheld device the
catch though was that you could only be
like 15 ft away from the console so it
wasn't actually all that useful but then
again that never stopped the DS Wii or
3DS something that did stop the Wii U
though was terrible marketing for
starters they decided to name the
console the Wii U and the design looked
almost identical to a Wii at least to
the average person the main controller
that you were supposed to use to control
the Wii U other than the gam pad was
also just regular old Wii remotes so it
was natural that many people thought
that the Wii U was just a pro version of
the Wii as opposed to a next gen console
leading to really poor sales amongst
casual buyers as for the core Gaming
Community these guys did know that the
Wii U was a new console but it didn't
appeal to them all that much again it
seemed like Nintendo was just putting
all of their eggs in the gimmick basket
instead of really pushing forward the
industry in terms of performance so much
of the core gaming audience preferred to
just get an Xbox One or a PS4 and all of
this was only made worse by positive
feedback loops you see the better a
console sells the more game developers
that get on board and the more games
that come out the better the console
sells however this works the other way
too the worse the console cells the
fewer game developers that get on board
and the fewer games that come out the
worse the conso Sals this eventually
leads to a deep dark abyss in terms of
sales which is precisely what happened
to the Wii U the Wii U would end up
being Nintendo's worst selling console
of all time only selling 13.5 million
units for perspective that's only about
1/8 of the Wii honestly this was quite a
shame because despite the Wii U's flaws
and shortcomings it was actually a super
underrated console with a bunch of solid
first-party games like Super Mario 3D
World Mario Kart 8 and Splatoon in fact
a lot of these games would just get
ported to the switch and end up selling
really well so the Wii U definitely had
some hidden gems but in terms of sales
and financials it was nothing but a
failure and given that the 3DS and the
2DS were also starting to wind down in
terms of sales Nintendo needed a new
hero product enter the
switch by the late 2010s Nintendo's
financials were looking more depressing
than ever with Revenue being down nearly
80% and that's why in 2017 Nintendo
would make an unprecedented move the
move to combine their waning handheld
business with their waning console
business the idea was obvious vious ly
that these businesses might be able to
accomplish more together but it also
meant that Nintendo was risking it all
on just one console the switch to be
honest the switch didn't solve any
fundamental issue with the Wii U being a
hybrid console it was not even
comparable to Playstation or Xbox in
terms of performance and Nintendo was
still very much betting on a gimmick to
sell the switch the gimmick that you
could take the switch on the go in that
sense the switch was really just a
better version of the Wii U it even had
a bunch of the same games but where the
switch really made a difference was
marketing the name of the console itself
was indicative of what the console was
all about it was about switching between
handheld mode and console mode the
switch also had new controllers a new
console design and a brand new
generation of kits to Market to and it
turns out that this facelift is all the
Wii U needed in order to go from being
Nintendo's worst selling car console to
being almost their best selling console
the switch currently stands at 132
million unit sold meaning that they may
even be able to take the crown for the
bestselling console of all time but that
title is rather misleading because the
switch isn't directly comparable to any
other console on that list because it's
a handheld and a console the Wii and the
DS sold a combined 255 million units so
from that perspective the switch is only
doing about half as well and that's why
Nintendo's financials are also doing
only half as well they basically cash in
on both their handheld audience and
their console audience to make the
switch a success but maybe that's not
such a bad thing due to the rise of
smartphones selling a separate handheld
gaming device is harder than ever so
combining handheld and console and
developing games separately for
smartphones may have actually been a
good long-term move for Nintendo
speaking of mobile games while
Nintendo's mobile games are extremely
popular clocking in at 738 million total
downloads it seems that their mobile
Revenue has actually been on decline for
4 years now not even benefiting from the
pandemic and given that Nintendo
themselves have admitted that their
mobile games aren't meant to be massive
Revenue drivers it doesn't seem like
Mobile gaming is the new era of Nintendo
either all of this makes it very
unlikely that Nintendo will ever revisit
that Peak that they said way back in the
late 2000s but maybe that too is not
such a bad that thing while Revenue
isn't doing better than ever Nintendo
has figured out how to make similar
levels of profit by doubling their
margins from 177% to 35% so while they
may not be as ubiquitous as they once
were they are as profitable as they once
were whether this success continues on
into the future is of course very
dependent on how their next console
performs but seeing Nintendo experiment
with new avenues like Mobile gaming and
even movies it seems that Nintendo is
open to adapting and evolving but only
time will tell with historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times they still expect
people to use clunky Bond tables scroll
through long overwhelming lists and even
use Virtual keyboards till recently and
that's why we created our own modern
Bond platform Silo at Silo we prioritize
the user experience and the the ease of
finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust so that you too can
easily lock in high yields also choosing
a strong user experience does not mean
sacrificing unsafety every Salo account
is insured by $500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC Insurance also
all funds deposited on the platform will
be maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below someone else
who stuck in a similar situation to
Nintendo is Sony who is now largely
dependent on the PS5 check out this
video to learn more but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one